تستمر في اسرائيل التظاهرات ضد مضي حكومه
نتنياهو في تعديلات ترمي للحد من صلاحيات
القضاء وتتزامن الاحتجاجات مع جلسات تصويت
مرتقبه للكنيست على خطه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه المثيره للجدل وكذلك مع تصاعد
مظاهر العصيان داخل الجيش الاسرائيلي وصى
تحذيرات على اعلى المستويات العسكريه
والسياسيه من تداعياتها على الامن القومي
للبلاد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما المرحله التي توشك
معركه التعديلات القضائيه على الدخول فيها
مع تصاعد الاحتجاجات ضدها بالتزامن مع
تصويت مرتقب للكنيست وواسطه تفاقما لمظاهر
العصيان داخل الجيش وتتالي التحذيرات من
خطورتها على اسرائيل وكيف ستتعامل حكومه
نتنياهو مع الاحتمالات التي يقترب منها
ملف التعديلات القضائيه بما يرتبط بها من
احتجاجات ومظاهر للعصيان العسكري واي
خيارات للمعارضه الاسرائيليه ازاء كل ذلك
وما الانعكاسات المستقبليه التي ستطول
صوره اسرائيل وسياسات حكومه نتنياهو حيال
الملفات الداخليه والخارجيه وكيف ستتعامل
واشنطن باعتبارها اكبر حليفا لتل ابيب مع
هذه التحولات المحتمله
[موسيقى]
لم تضع معركه التعديلات القضائيه في
اسرائيل اوزارها فاطراف الخلاف
يلازمون مواقفهم ومواقعهم في مواجهه باتت
اقرب الى عض للاصابع زعيم المعارضه
الاسرائيليه يئير لافيثا في جديد تصريحاته
ان حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو تقود اسرائيل
الى كارثه محققه نتنياهو المصر على مشروعه
للتعديلات القضائيه تطرق لمظاهر العصيان
العسكري فقال لا يمكن لمجموعه تعصي
الاوامر داخل الجيش ان تهدد الحكومه
المنتخبه قائله اذا لم تفعلوا ما نريد
سنغلق باب الامن ما يحدث داخل اسرائيل
يتردد صدى في الخارج خاصه في وقت يقوم فيه
الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق هرتزوك بزياره
الى واشنطن بعيده دعوه للحوار والتعقل بين
اطراف الازمان جهته البيت الابيض اكد
اجراء مكالمه بين الرئيس بايدن ونتنياهو
تض منت دعوه هذا الاخير لزياره واشنطن دون
تحديد لموعدها ووسط هذه التطورات كان
الكنيست قد وافق في قراءه اولى على تعديل
ما يعرف ببند المعقوليه وهو صلاحيه تتيح
رقابه قضائيه فاعله على السلطه التنفيذيه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من القدس مناحي
كلاين استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
بارلان ومن الناصره ايهاب جبارين المحلل
السياسي والباحث المختص في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه ومن واشنطن
مبعوثه الرئيس السابق بالكلينتون الى
مفاوضات السلام بالشرق الاوسط مرحبا بكم
جميعا نبدا معك سيد كلاين في القدس اذن
جلسه اقرار اولى وقراءه اولى
بطبيعه الحال لهذه التعديلات القضائيه
ستليها جلسات اخرى مرتقبه في ظل تصاعد
للاحتجاجات
ويعني تهديد بمظاهر للعصيان تطال حتى قطاع
كبير
للجيش
وايضا اصرار من قبل حكومه نتنياهو على
المضي قدما في مثل هذه التعديلات ما مصير
مثل هذه المعركه بين كل هذه الاطراف ضد
هذه التعديلات المثيره للجدل
مساء الخير من وجهه نظري نحن لا نتحدث عن
اصلاحات قضائيه في هذه المرحله بل نتحدث
عن تغيير للنظام في اسرائيل نحن نرى
الحكومه الاسرائيليه والائتلاف الحكوميه
الحاكم في اسرائيل في محاوله تغييرة
للنظام من نوع من الديمقراطيه الى
ديكتاتوريه في اسرائيل هذا ما نراه نتحدث
عن تغيير للنظام في اسرائيل وليس اصلاحات
قضائيه ولذلك الوحدات في الاحتياط في جيش
الدفاع الاسرائيلي ترفض الانضمام للخدمه
العسكريه خدمه
للدكتاتوريه قيد المنشا ولذلك نحن نرى
المراحل الاولى من حرب اهليه حيث اننا
لمده
اشهر شاهدنا حربا اهليه بارده والان تصبح
اسخن لا اعرف اين سوف ينتهي المطاف بنا
ولكننا وبكل تاكيد نتحدث عن نوع من الحرب
الاهليه من ضمن المجتمع الاسرائيلي
اليهودي
الفلسطينيون الاسرائيليون لا ياخذون طرفا
في هذه الحرب الاهليه
اذا ما استمرت الحكومه الاسرائيليه
بعدم اخذ المظاهرات بعين الاعتبار قد يؤدي
بها ذلك الى ازمه حقيقيه ليس فقط بين
المجتمع المدني والحكومه بل نتحدث عن ازمه
دستوريه لانه بعد انتهاء من دراسه
التشريعات في الاسبوع المقبل سوف يكون
هناك طلب للمحكمه العليا
لكي تتخذ القرار بالنسبه الى القراءه
الثانيه والقراءه الثالثه وما اذا كان
مناقدا للدستور في اسرائيل او اتمكن
مناسبا طيب
عند ما تعيشه هذه الاجواء التي تعيشها
اسرائيل سيد ايهاب جبارين مرئي بمثل هذا
الكلام الذي تحدث عنه
ضمن معركه فرد العضلات ان كان من قبل
حكومه نتنياهو الذي يبدو بانه مصر على
الذهاب الى مثل هذه التعديلات والمعارضه
التي يعني لا تالوا جهدا بكل اوراقها
للضغط باتجاه عدم الذهاب لهذه التعديلات
نعم مساء الخير بدون نجاك يعني يجب ان
نستثني مشهد التراكميه السياسيه في داخل
اسرائيل يعني هذا المشهد لم يكن وليد
اللحظه نحن نتحدث منذ عام 2018 يعني على
مدار خمس سنوات على الاقل هنالك حاله من
الفوضى السياسيه بل عدم الاستقرار السياسي
في داخل المشهد الاسرائيلي ككل فبالتالي
ما وصل اليه يعني في نهايه المطاف السته
اشهر الاخيره 29 الاسبوع الاخيره هو في
النهايه المطاف تراكمات بدات عبر مشاهد
انتخابيه متراكمه سلسله من الانتخابات
المتراكمه تضمنت الكثير من الاحتجاجات في
داخل بلفور او في غيرها والان نحن نرى كيف
ذلك ينجم عنه ما يسمى بالتعديلات القضائيه
السؤال الى اسرائيل الى اين سوف تتجه في
نهايه المطاف يجب ان نتذكر
الائتلافيه هي
رهينه بيد الصهيونيه الدينيه يعني ليس فقط
بنيامين نتنياهو من يدير هذا المشهد بل
الصهيونيه الدينيه لديها ضلع كبير في داخل
هذا المشهد وهنا يجب ان نتذكر انه منذ عام
خطه الانفصال لشارون الصهيونيه الدينيه
تفككت
بمفهوم الى جماعات متناثره لكن في النصف
عام الاخير او انشئنا ان نقول في السته
اعوام الاخيره هي بدات تتراكم لتاخذ
وتسيطر على المشهد في داخل اسرائيل بشكل
كبير وتقيده الى مرحله اخرى من الصهيونيه
الصهيونيه الاكثر تشددا الاكثر تذمتا التي
ربما حتى لا يطاق يعني
منتوجها ليس فقط اتجاه الفلسطينيين بل حتى
اتجاه الاسرائيليين العلمانيين وهنا في
نهايه المطاف هذه النقطه التي يجب نقف
عندها اسرائيل الكلاسيكيه التي
ندركها التي يعني تعايشت على مدار 75 عام
هي نتاج ووليده هذا اليسار في هذه المرحله
اليمين يحاول ان يسيطر عليها يحاول
بنيامين نتنياه هنا يجب ان نقف عند نقطه
معينه منح بيجن عندما دخل الى الحكم كان
احد اهم الماخذ عليه من اليمين انه يفعل
ذلك الانقلاب في النفوذ والسلطه لليمين
وتركها بيد اليسار
نتنياهو الان ولانه رهينه بيض الصهيونيه
الدينيه يحاول تقييد ويحاول مسايره هذا
اليمين المتطرف بان ياخذ ويسيطر على زمام
الحكم في داخل المشهد الاسرائيلي وربما
هذا هو الانقلاب في نهايه المطاف بل هنا
يمكن ان نقول ونستدرك ان هنالك باتل
الكثير من الاقوال في داخل المشاهد
السياسيه لدى محللين سياسيين
فيهم الذين يقولونها بصيح العباره ربما
بات هنالك حاجه للحديث عن مملكه يهوذا
لليهود المتدينين المتزمتين والمستوطنين
ومملكه اسرائيل للعلمانيين اي بمعنى اخر
مات واضحا للجميع ان لا يوجد هنالك مشهد
لكيفيه عوده اسرائيل الى ما كانت عليه قبل
خمسه اعوام سيناريو الخروج من هذا المشهد
بات واضحا للجهتين انه بات بعيدا
وحاله الانسجام التي كانت ما قبل ذلك لن
تعود
الخروج سيد ريتشرد
كيف ينظر في واشنطن لما يجري الان من
عمليه الشد ما بين معسكر الصهيونيه
الدينيه والمعسكر الصهيونيه
العلمانيه والى اي درجه
واشنطن تخشى على الحاله السياسيه المستقره
في اسرائيل
لعقود خلت
البيت الابيض وبايدا يرون ما يحصل في
اسرائيل عنه امر مؤسف جدا
من ناحيه التاريخيه الولايات المتحده
لطالما دعمت اسرائيل ليس لانه دوله يهوديه
بل لانها دوله الديمقراطيه وان ما يحاول
يقوم بها انها يثير التساؤل والشك في
مساله مدى اهتمامه التزامه بالديمقراطيه
الكامله ليس هناك ديموقراطيه كامله مثاليه
في اي بلد ولكنه ما يحاول ان يقوم به هو
يجعل يجعل اسرائيل اقل مثاليه وقله جوده
وهذه مشكله
في جميع حسابات وعندما التحدث رئيس بايدن
مع نتنياهو امس قال قال
انما يقوم به نتنياهو يحاول القيام به في
مزال القضاء غير حكيم وامر لا ترحب به
الولايات المتحده
يبدو ان نتنياهو اقترح على
سيخفف
المسيره هذا في هذا المسير في هذا الاتجاه
واذا هذا لم يحصل في المشكله تكون اكبر ما
شاهدناه
ونشدهم من هذه التظاهرات التي تظهر
باعداد لا سابقه لا نظرا لحجم سكان
اسرائيل وبالتالي يبدو الامور التفسير نحو
الاسوا سيد كلاين هل الغاء التعديلات ممكن
كما تريد تريدها المعارضه الغاء هذه
التغييرات ممكن كما تريدها المعارضه
وبالتالي ماذا سينتج عنها في حال الغيات
وفي حال لم تلغى هذه التغييرات القضائيه
ايضا ما الذي سينتج عنه
تم الغاء التشريعات يتعين على نتن ياهو ان
يغير الائتلاف الحكومي وحزب لقيت وحزب
ياتي الى الائتلاف لكي
يستبدل
الدينيين المتطرفين او المتدينه
المتطرفين
وجانس ليس بالحليف التقليدي الطبيعي
لنتنياهو وبالتالي سوف يصبح
رهينه هذا التحالف لذلك الخيارات امامنا
نتنياهو هي صعبه للغايه اذا ما اختار ان
يمضي قدما
وينتهي من المرحله الاولى من التشريع الذي
يؤدي الى الحاق ضرر جسيم
بالقضاء وسوف يكون هناك
استئناف او طلب امام المحكمه الع القرار
بان ذلك هو مناقض للدستور الاسرائيلي وهذا
يؤدي بنا الى ازمه حقيقيه بين الحكومه
والمحكمه العليا وان الحكومه
وايضا الجهات التابعه لها على سبيل المثال
رئاسه الاركان في الجيش الاسرائيلي
والخدمات والاجهزه الامنيه لديها معضله هل
تتبع الحكومه او المحكمه العليا اعتقد
انها سوف تختار بان تتبع قرارات المحكمه
العليا ولو ان بعض الوحدات على المستوى
المتدني قد تتبع اوامر الحكومه
ايضا هي معنيه ايضا بخيارات المستقبل ماذا
ان لم تكن هذه الاحتجاجات والتهديد
بالصيان خاصه في صفوف الامن والجيش فعاله
ماذا لو لم تكن فعاله وجرى المضي باتجاه
احداث تغيير ات قضائيات تشريعيه كما
يريدها نتنياهو
اظن ان المشهد في داخل اسرائيل الان
رهينه والسيناريوهات المستقبليه هي رهينه
امرين اثنين او خطين انشئنا القول يعني
بمثابه المطاف النقطه الاولى هي حصانه
الجيش وهو جيش يعني باتا واضحا ان لديه
يعني تفاعلاته بكل ما يخص هذا الشان هنا
يجب ان نتذكر نقطه مهمه جدا لربما فاتت عن
الجميع انه على مدار 50 عام كان جيش هو
البؤره التي يدخل بها الشاشه الى سلطه
الحكم والنفوذ في داخل اسرائيل يعني على
مدار حتى سنوات الالفين
المتقدمه كان هنالك يعني مشهد اغلبيه
الجنرالات واساء هيئه الاركان كانوا هم من
يتصدرون رئاسه الحكومه في اسرائيل في
السنوات الاخيره العقدين الاخيرين هنالك
تبدل حتى على مستوى اعضاء الكنيست وبادت
يعني الجيش همشا في داخل المشهد السياسي
لكنه بطبيعه الحال ياخذ زمام الامور من
اماكن اخرى والمشاهد اخرى الان بطبيعه
الحال مدى حصانه الجيش امام كل هذا المشهد
يعني في نهايه المطاف هنالك الكثير من
السيناريوهات في العصر الحديث عن يعني
تازم الحاله الى حاله امنيه
خطيره يمكن القول وهذا ربما قدرت قد اشرت
اليه قناه مكان قبل اسمه او اسبوعين ان من
الممكن ان تتدهور هذه الحاله الى حاله
امنيه ولكن هذا كله في نهايه المطاف انا
بالناظر مرهون بمدى حصانه الجيش وليس
اتجاه التهديدات الخارجيه يعني في نهايه
المطاف ليس الحديث عما اذا سوف يلتزم جنود
الاحتياط
بتداعيات امنيه خارجيه بل السؤال كيف
سيكون ودهم اتجاه التداعيات الداخليه هذا
هو في نهايه المطاف يعني في داخل المشهد
الامريكي على سبيل المثال الولايات
المتحده الوليده في نهايه المطاف كل
الخلاف الدستوري لم ينجم عنه حرب اهليه
الا عندما تدخل الجيش وفرق الولايات الى
شماليه وجنوبيه وفي ديمقراطيات او حتى في
دول اقل يعني
اقل حصانه راي الجيش تدخل
وتدهورت الامور بسرعه اكبر الان ما هو
موقف هذا الجيش هذا الحصانه الاولى التي
اسرائيل راهينتها ورهينه الثانيه بنظره هي
الاغتيالات السياسيه في الذاكره الجماعيه
الاسرائيليه اغتيالها بان كان هو احد اهم
الامور التي تقف عندها الخطوط الحمراء
وبنظر اذا تم اعاده هذا المشهد وليس فقط
على مستوى رئاسه حكومه بل حتى على مستوى
اقل من ذلك على مستوى النشطاء في داخل
الاحتجاجات على سبيل المثال هذا الامر
ممكن ان ياخذ اسرائيل الى مرحله اخرى
وسيناريوهات اخرى
تكون المعارضه فيها اشد فتكا بنظر مما هي
عليه الان وفي ظل كل هذا المشهد سيد
ريتشرد
واشنطن ترقب ما يجري في ظل علاقه فاتره ما
بين
نتنياهو وبين بايدن يعني ولكن هذا الفتور
ربما جرى الاعلان عنه البارحه بانه سيجري
ترتيب للقاء
من الان حتى نهايه هذه السنه في واشنطن
تمت دعوه في النهايه الى البيت الابيض
واشنطن البيت الابيض بايدن كيف تراقب ما
يجري هل هو يعني ياتي من باب العلاقه
المباشره ما بين بنيامين نتنياهو بايدن ام
ان الصوره اوسع من ذلك
اولا
بالموجبه التقارير الصحفيه فان الدعوه لم
تخن بالضروره من البيت لبيت الابيض لحصول
اجتماع في الولايات المتحده هناك فرق بين
الاثنين وهذا بالتاكيد يشير الى انه لنقل
انه خلال اجتماع جميع العامه للامم
المتحده مثلا قد يلتقي بايدنعه في مكان ما
الامر مختلف من دعوه من للبيت الابيض
واعتقد ان يعرف ذلك وبالتالي اعتقد بايدن
اراد ان يقول بانه انا لا انظر بشكل مرتاح
واؤيد ما تفعلونه وانا لدي مشاعر عميقه
لاسرائيل وانت رئيس الحكومه وبالتالي قد
نحتاج الى تبادل الحديث لكن لابد ان تعرف
بان قد تتعلق الامر لا يتم المتحده انما
تقوم تقوم به غير حكيم وغير جيد وبالتالي
اعتقد انه على المستوى العسكري وعلى مستوى
الاستخبارات الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
سيواصلان التعاون كما فعلوا منذ عقود ولكن
على المستوى السياسي
اعتقد هناك بالتاكيد نظره او فكره بان ان
نتنياهو
يتمنى
ويشجع العوده الى البيت الابيض ويبدا هنا
قلنا هذا هو مخطئ في تفكير تفكيره بان
هناك احتمال بعوده ترامب
وبالتالي اعتقد كان يعتقد ذلك يا فهل
يستطيع من ناحيه اساسيه
ان يبقى
اليمنيين في تحلفه الى جانبه او يتركهم
للتوجه نحو الوسط هذا ممكن لكن هل هذا
ممكن ام لا هذا هو السؤال الحالي
وان نشهد في الولايات المتحده ايضا نفس
الامر فاذا اليمين يحاول السحبه ترامبو
وغيره مزيدا نحو التطرف واعتقد ان هذه
مشكله
الا اذا استطاع ان يواجههم ولكن حاليا ليس
هناك ما يدل ان بامكانه ان يفعل ذلك
الرئيس
الاسرائيلي قبل ان يذهب الى واشنطن الى
الحوار ما بين الحكومه وبين المعارضه ما
الذي عساء ان يفعله في مثل هذه الزياره في
مثل هذا التوقيت الحساس بالنسبه
لما تعيشه اسرائيل
بحسب ما ارى ان الرئيس الامريكي
سوف يرسل رساله عبر الرئيس الاسرائيلي الى
رئيس مجلس الوزراء نتنياهو وهذه الرساله
سوف تكون الرساله الامريكيه وايضا لربما
هناك رساله من نتنياهو ومن الرئيس بنفسه
ان الاحاديث على مستوى مكتب الرئيس او
المفاوضات انتهت الى لا شيء وبالتالي لا
ارى كيفيه استعاده هذا الحوار هناك فجوه
وهو كبيره بين مكتب الرئيس وطرف الاخر
ونحن لا نتحدث عن
مفاوضات بين زعماء السياسيين بل نتحدث عن
الائتلاف من جهه
وحركه في الميد مجموعه اخرى خلف الحكومه
هناك ائتلاف متدين متشدد عازم على تغيير
الحكم في اسرائيل والمجتمع الاسرائيلي
لانه هو بالنسبه اليهم من غير الممكن حكم
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله وفي الوقت
نفسه ان تكون اسرائيل ديمقراطيه او تدعي
بانها ديمقراطيه هم يودون الوصول الى تفوق
اليهود في المنظومه القانونيه القضائيه
وان يكون ذلك جزء لا يتجزا من دوله
اسرائيل هذا هو الهدف من الحركه الدينيه
والخطط هي بعيده الامد ليست على الامد
القريب طبعا نتنياهو يفكر بالامد القريب
ودعونا نرى ما اذا كان بامكانه ان يواجه
الاعتراف الحكومه
مثلا ينهي هذا الاستقطاب الحاد ما بين
حكومه ومعارضه
هي نقطه مهمه جدا هنالك الكثير من
المحاولات في داخل اسرائيل لكي تحاول ان
تحتوي هذا المشهد يعني ان كان محاوله
سابقا بينيجانس حول ان يكون هو الشخص الذي
يتواجد في المركز
وغيرها من المحاولات الاخرى ولكن هنالك
نقطه مهمه جدا يجب ان نتداركها ونفهمها
جيدا لكي نفهم مدى هذا الشرخ نحن هنا
نتحدث عن المنطقه الرماديه الوسطى والفيصل
يعني على مدى سنوات الفيصل ما بين اليمين
واليسار الاسرائيلي كان القضيه الفلسطينيه
في
العقدين الاخيرين او الخمسه عشر عام
الاخيره
وهمش هذا الفيصل وهمش القضيه الفلسطينيه
تماما ولم تعد هي الفيصل ما بين اليمين
واليسار الاسرائيلي ونجم عنها بالتالي
فيصل جديد الا وهو الصهيونيه بحثا وهذا ما
نشهده الان يعني ما بين الصهيونيه
العلمانيه
المتشدده وما بين الليبراليه ولا هنا ولا
يوجد هناك الكثير من المساحات في نهايه
المطاف وما بين المعسكرين فبالتالي هذا ما
بعيدا
شكرا جزيلا لك من الناصره ايهاب جبارين
المحلل السياسي والباحث المختص في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه واشكر ايضا ضيفي من القدس
مناح استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
مبعوث الرئيس السابق بالكنتون الى مفاوضات
السلامه بالشرق الاوسط
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]